[Music]
to me black history month is a time for
reflection and inspiration
reflecting on the intellectual and
societal contributions the black
community has made the world
reflecting on the visionaries who
rallied against seemingly insurmountable
prejudice and violence to make those
contributions
and reflecting on those lost along the
way
this month reminds me that the trials of
our present will one day become the
reflections of our tomorrow and inspires
me to seek to be counted among those who
have contributed to that future
[Music]
black history month is an occasion to
reflect on the struggle of the past
generations for freedom
give thanks to our ancestors for being
brave and appreciate the inspiring
progress people from the african
diaspora have made
without them
walls and barriers would not have been
broken down
looking forward we can learn from this
as we seek to make our future a better
and more inclusive one for those who
come after us
black history month is a time for me to
reflect and celebrate
i reflect on the words in spite of when
i think about black history month i
often think about the magnitude of what
black people across generations have
accomplished almost always in spite of
something whether it be adversity or
presumption of inequality
black history month is also a time when
i celebrate black people's prevailing
resilience
and the vitality that sustains our
influential progress creativity and hope
our world isn't perfect by any means but
black history month provides a healthy
blend of celebration and reflective
criticism
they may sound contradictory but i found
those two to be a necessary pair for
progress driven by hope
black history month is a time to
celebrate all the progress we've made
while acknowledging the immense work
that still needs to be done to get to an
equitable plan
it reminds us that progress is not
linear
but arcs towards justice with enough
work and sacrifice
it's a month of jubilation for the
progress we've made
sorrow for the leaders we've lost
and hope that we can and will leave the
world a better place for future
generations
[Music]
black history month has always been a
complex time for me
a time for learning and celebration to
build a deeper appreciation for the rich
history and progress of the
african-american community
a time for reflection to ask myself what
more can i be doing for the black
community and to also constructively
challenge those in positions of power
around me to do more as well
and lastly a time for fellowship to
navigate all the complexities of the
month with a community that is
incredibly supportive and one that i
could not be more proud to be a part of
black history month is a time to remind
myself of the sacrifices that were made
by my ancestors and the many more that
have come before me
it is a time to reflect on the reasons
why i have the privileges i do today
and the responsibilities that are
attached to them
there's a time to celebrate the
accomplishments of the american negro
ethnicity in spite of the adversity and
institutional challenges that have and
continue to work against it
for me black history month represents a
time of reflection about who i really am
and where i come from
as someone born in africa
raised in canada and now living in the
us i have seen and experienced just how
varied black identity can be
we are far from being a monolith
and yet
we share a relentless spirit that allows
us to not just survive no matter where
we are but more importantly to thrive
so
onwards and upwards we go
[Music]
to me black history month is not only a
time to reflect on the sacrifices
resilience and accomplishments of those
that came before us
it's a time where i recognize and
celebrate the trials and progress we are
making today for our future generations
it's a reminder that we should take time
to reflect
celebrate ourselves and not water
ourselves down
lock history month for me is a
celebration of blackness our successes
our wins our progress our contributions
to the world
our multifaceted and diverse history and
stories
it's also about reflecting on our
progress through adversity while looking
ahead to all the work that still needs
to be done
black history month means making space
to pause reflect
celebrate and connect
it means acknowledging and celebrating
the resilience and beauty of black
people
it means reflecting on black history and
thinking about what i can do to shape
black futures for the better
you